[Music]
have you ever felt
like it was so hot out that you could
cook an
egg on the road do you enjoy
incredibly spicy foods just for the
thrill of it
well imagine living in an area
that's as hot as fire around 1 000
degrees
could anything survive or would we all
be barbecued
it's time to fire up the grill as things
are going to get toasty
what would happen if the atmosphere was
as hot as lava would
our air catch fire if it was heated to
1000 degrees
and could life survive this extreme heat
if it only lasted 5 seconds
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the earth's atmosphere became
superheated to 1000 degrees
for 5 seconds throughout history
earth has experienced some pretty
extreme heat
ranging from 204 degrees
to 2027 degrees
mind you these temperatures occurred
billions of years ago
during earth's cooling process but
certain events provided temporary heat
pulses
hot enough to almost wipe out all life
on earth the
asteroid impact that demolished the
dinosaurs
managed to bump up the global
temperature by 5 degrees
for 100 000 years
this impact was equivalent to more than
1 billion hiroshima bombs
and yet life still managed to survive
so how did anything manage to live
through this
well life survived that devastating
asteroid because
it was a localized event areas close to
the impact
experienced an intense but short-lived
heat blast that lasted
one and a half minutes it was so hot
that
parts of earth's atmosphere began to
boil
that's around 20 times hotter than any
human
could tolerate however
simulation research suggests that this
heat
wasn't evenly distributed across the
surface of the earth
areas further from the impact
experienced a less intense heat wave
that
lasted up to seven and a half minutes
what's most peculiar is that researchers
discovered
that the areas closest to the impact
didn't catch fire
rather it was in the areas further away
from the blast that went up in flames
while these areas weren't as hot as the
impact site
the heat lasted long enough for plants
to ignite
causing devastating wildfires
okay but what would happen if we cranked
up the heat
throughout the atmosphere would just
five seconds of heat
be enough to wipe us out
well it's not the five seconds that we
need to be worried about
it's what happens after the first thing
to catch fire would be our trees
igniting wildfires on a global scale
if you live in a log cabin you might
want to relocate
the spread of wildfires worldwide could
prevent animals from moving to safety
unless they were
deep underwater any humans outside
would experience second-degree burns
inhaling the air would be lethal and
would destroy your respiratory
tract people who inhale smoke from fires
have a greater risk of death than burn
victims
due to severe lung injuries we would all
have to hunker down
in a refrigerated bunker somewhere to
survive
and realistically it would take weeks or
even months for the wildfires to go out
like with an asteroid impact the overall
global temperature
would increase several degrees lasting
for hundreds of thousands of years
we would be facing even more extreme
global warming effects like
dangerous weather mass extinctions and
food shortages worldwide the most
damaging effects would be seen
in earth's lowest atmosphere layer the
troposphere
where the highest density of gas is you
might think that the
air would catch fire at 1000 degrees but
for this to occur we need a source of
fuel
and an oxidizer oxygen in the atmosphere
is the oxidizer but it has no fuel to
react with
also about 78 of our atmosphere
is the inert gas nitrogen inert gases
have extremely low reactivity and can't
ignite
so what about higher up in the
thermosphere where the nitrogen
levels are lower well even if we had the
right mix of fuel and oxidizer
at such high altitudes the oxygen
density
is so extremely low that gas particles
don't collide as often as they do closer
to the surface
while earth doesn't experience such
extreme temperatures in its atmosphere
these days
other exoplanets like wasp 189b
reach surface temperatures of 3 200
degrees
this happens because it orbits its
massive star
so closely that it absorbs most of its
solar radiation
thankfully we are a safe enough distance
from
our sun to keep things cool dude
time to catch some gnarly waves and work
on my tan
man but if
we somehow accidentally detonated an
antimatter bomb here on earth
well oh boy that's a story
for another what if
you